hey youtubers and the 500 million
adolescent girls that are out there in
the world living in developing countries
um we had a meeting today that I just
came out of where we had over 25
companies and we had the head of un aids
UNICEF the UN High Commissioner for
Refugees we had the head of some of the
largest NGOs in the world and they all
got together and we talked about you we
talked about what we need to do to
change more challenges so obviously the
situation for adolescent girls in the
world it's really challenging we talked
about the chapel unique challenges that
you face and what we need to do and it's
time to stop talking about it but
actually really take action so what we
agreed to do was to count you first of
all right now the data that's collected
around the world by all these important
organizations doesn't reflect you just
break you into an HR that can be
identified clumped into women or your
content to you through all identifiers I
agreed to do that so that then we can do
the most important thing which are in
the best division because real money
needs to go to programs that will help
improve your lives so we talked about
how we would specifically do that in
here take leadership roles to make that
a nap anyway and then thirdly we talked
about advocacy and how we need to speak
out on your head and give you a means to
have your voices heard but people can
hear your stories and hear how the life
of a girl in poverty it's uniquely
challenging and uniquely needs to be
addressed by world leaders around the
world and if you care about the
environment you care about the poverty
you care about any issue out there in
the world investing new girl the new is
the most important thing that we can do
and today there were about a hundred
important world leaders who got together
in a room and made you a priority and
told you I told each other what they
were going to do in front of each other
to improve your lives we're going to
post the action plan it's a ten-point
action plan and we're going to post that
on nike foundation org and UN foundation
org and the Coalition for adolescent
girls org and that's a group of all of
us who are going to work together to
hopefully make your lives better so I
hope this is good news for you thank you
so much for putting the video together
and we hope you girls have your chance
to transform the world of your family
other communities and your country
because you're the most powerful people
in the world it's just the world doesn't
know it yet